[Arabic recitation]
in which the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam was once on a journey. He was
traveling and he had of course a caravan
of companions with him as they would
travel.
And as he was traveling he sent word
back
through the caravan. Now, I want you to
imagine what this kind of looks like
when you have a caravan of people
traveling.
This caravan, depending on if it's a
military
or if it's tradesmen, it could be
anywhere from five or six camels or
people all the way to 30, 40, 50,000
people who are all traveling together in
this caravan. And so a caravan could
snake on for miles and it would take
time for word to be passed back all the
way to the end of the caravan and for
word to be passed back up to the front
of the caravan etc. This is how they
communicated.
And the prophet sallall.aii wasallam
traditionally would travel at the front
of his caravan. He would be in the very
front. His closest companions would be
around him and with him. His generals,
his advisors, Abu Bakr, Omar, Ali,
Abu Abnah,
these different companions, they would
be up there and the caravan would go
back far. However, after Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala revealed the verse in
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala commanded Lord
to leave in the morning before
and to follow his family out to safety
out of Sodom and Gomorrah.
After this verse was revealed, the
prophet Sam
started to travel at the very end of the
caravan. If you notice in the story of
when they didn't notice that was not in
her that she wasn't in her,
you know, it's a little room that
they would place on top of the camel.
she would be in there and because she
was so light and she was so young, they
didn't notice four big men carrying this
thing. They didn't notice she wasn't in
there and she was only noticed to be
missing by someone that was traveling
days after the caravan. It's because the
prophet sallallah.aii wasallam and his
wives would be at the back of the
caravan. That's why. So if they got left
behind, they wouldn't notice until a day
or two later.
So the prophet sallallah.aii wasallam
was on this journey
and suddenly he sent word with his
messengers through the caravan.
He sent word that every
tendon
be cut off of the necks of camels.
What's that mean? Cut off the tendons of
the necks of camels.
What is
this? was the superstition in the time
of Jahia.
Warriors,
their closest companion was their sword
and their bow.
Their bow is their livelihood. It was
their protection. It was what they
hunted with. It's what they fed their
family with. It was with them wherever
they went. And how would they string
their bows? They used to use tendons
from camels. you know, the tendons,
these tendons that are very kind of have
a a bit of an some elasticity to them.
They would use these tendons.
They didn't they hadn't discovered
rubber yet at that time. So, they would
use these tendons
and stretch them tight to be able to
string their bows and use these to to
shoot arrows.
And this is referred to in Arabic as a
wet. A wet is a tendon, right?
And they also used to use these tendons
as handles on their swords,
right? Because it would be kind of
grippy, almost almost like
rubber. So they would wrap the handle of
their swords with these tendons, right?
And these things would wear out over
time. The tendon would get stretched out
to a point where it needs a new one. And
so they would take this tendon off of
the handle of their sword or take it off
of the string of their bow. And they
wouldn't just throw it away. They would
say to themselves, "This tendon here was
a part of my sword. It was a part of my
bow. It's been with me for years. I've
killed how many enemies with it? I've
defended my honor with it, etc. And I've
lived long enough to tell the tale.
Therefore, this is now a lucky tendon.
This is called a
And so now they would take these used
tendons and they would hang them on
their house, their their their
camps or they would hang them most
predominantly around the necks of their
camels.
Right? And they believed that this would
repel the evil eye and it would repel
evil spirits and it would repel evil jin
and
right and this was referred to as
this is what they called it in Arabic.
Now in Islam,
this was also referred to as a tim.
What is a tim? It comes from the root
word a t. A tam is to make something
whole, to make it complete. They viewed
that this emulate would complete their
entourage, complete their ensemble. It
would protect them from evil spirits. It
would ward off evil eye, etc. And so
they would hang these things on their
hands. They would wear them on their
hands. Sometimes they would hang them
around their children's necks if they
were worried about their children. They
would put them under the under the
pillows of their children to ward off
evil spirits when the children slept.
They would put them on their camels just
people hang them on their rearview
mirror today. Same thing, same belief
system.
And so the prophet sallall.aii wasallam
sent word through the caravan that not
one of these is to be left hanging
around the neck or hand of anyone or
animal.
And then he sent word
[Arabic recitation]
"Whoever
hangs or whoever
dawns a tim
or a a an emu,
then this person has fallen into a type
of shik.
This person has committed an act of
shik. This person has fallen into an act
of superstition which is considered to
be a type of shift. Now the concept
behind this
is found everywhere in every country in
every people all over the world. It just
has a different look to it.
In some in the Arab world at that time
they use these old tendons, these old
strings from their bows and their armor.
In other countries, they'll use pieces
of metal. In other countries, they'll
use a bracelet that they put on the
child ever since the child is born. And
as the child gets older, it'll be a
bigger bracelet all the way until
they're adults until they die. And this
is all that has different looks to it.
It has different outward appearances to
it, but it all roots back to the same
concept. What is that concept? The
concept is an emulet or a charm that a
person will wear on his per on his body
or on his children or on his house or on
his car or over something that is
precious to them and in their belief it
will ward off evil spirits or jin or
whatever it is. This is referred to in
Islam as aim
and this is considered to be a type of
shik in Islam.
Once a group of young men came to the
prophet Sam
to give be to him to pledge
allegiance to him. And the way that they
would pledge allegiance is they would
come and the person pledging would take
the prophet's hand sallallahu alaihi
wasallam and the prophet would tell him
certain things to pledge allegiance to
and they would repeat after him.
And so this group had come and and they
all pledged allegiance to him except for
one of these young men. The prophet
sallallah.aii alaihi wasallam seemed to
go out of his way to ignore him. He
didn't look at him. He didn't speak to
him. He took the allegiance of everyone
else except for this young man. And so
the others they asked, they said, "Yeah,
our our friend here, you didn't take his
allegiance." Listen to what he said. He
said,
he said, "The reason is he has on his
hand an amulet.
He has on his hand." They used to wear
this wrap on their hand that they
believed would protect them from evil
spirits or protect them from fever
and stuff that, you know, illness,
things that. And so
this young man, he heard the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam say that they're
saying you you didn't pledge take the
pledge of our friend. He said because he
has an amulet wrapped around his wrist.
How can he take the prophet's hand while
sayingahill
I pledge to upholdahill
while simultaneously
upholding at the same time. It can't
work. That allegiance is neither neither
effective nor is it valid. And so the
boy, the young man, he heard this and he
cut this off of his hand and the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam then took his hand
and he pled allegiance to him as the
rest of his companions did. The
narrations in this regard are very
numerous throughout the Quran throughout
the sunnah of the prophet sallall.aii
alaihi wasallam
generalities in the Quran and specifics
which are mentioned in the prophet's
sunnah but all of this roots back to one
superstition and that is if I have this
particular thing it's going to bring me
good luck or it's going to ward off bad
luck or bad or misfortune right you have
and don't think that we in the modern
days today because we have fancy
technology and We have GPS and
we have iPhones that we have risen above
these superstitions. They sell them
right there in the drugstore. The every
pharmacy you've ever walked into has
these emulets and they have amulets made
out of brass. And it was believed by the
ancient Romans that brass would help you
with arthritis. Right? This is an
amulet. This is exactly what it is.
These beliefs are taken from that. Every
newspaper you've ever seen printed has a
section for horoscopes, a section that
is dedicated to a
we have basketball players, very famous
basketball players today in the NBA and
other and elsewhere that never change
their socks. They wear the same set of
socks they ever wore since they were
since they were a new pick, a new
player. Why? Because those are his lucky
socks. And if he doesn't wear his lucky
socks, he's not going to shoot the
basketball, right? And you've got
baseball players with a lucky glove and
they're they're or movie stars with a
lucky belt or Bruce Lee with his
lucky with his lucky mirror that they
would put as is in Chinese culture. The
point is is that we did not rise above
or transcend these superstitions.
They still exist. They're everywhere.
They're all around you. And this is
whyed is something that you have to go
out of your way to learn because the
scholars of Islam
refer to things emulets and
superstitions and so forth as landmines,
religious landmines that are in your
home that infiltrate themselves into
your life that you will only realize are
there and will only blow up in your face
when the angel of death comes to take
and collect your soul.
[Arabic recitation]